[Musik]
das ist mein Weg zur Arbeit wie bei
vielen anderen in diesem Land heißt das
Suchen nach einer Strecke mit möglichst
wenig Stau und dabei immer wieder
scheitern ja
[Musik]
wenn man das jeden Morgen hat
dann
weiß ich man ist eigentlich nicht mehr
sauer man ist auch nicht irgendwie
wütend oder so sondern
weiß ich nicht es ist so eine
verzweifelte Resignation lauter
Großbaustellen bei den Deutschland
hinterher hängt
und Papierberge wohin man guckt auch in
deutschen Behörden staut sich der
Fortschritt das scheint erstmal
umständlich zu sein ja warum das so ist
aber es muss ihm alles Schritt für
Schritt gehen ja umständlich analog und
penibel geregelt ist das der Weg in die
Zukunft für eine starke
Wirtschaftsnation wie digital würden Sie
Ihr Unternehmen aktuell beschreiben 10
ist total digital Null ist überhaupt
nicht digital
überall Zweifel vielleicht stehen wir
uns ja auch selbst im Weg
die machen ja auch Krach ne wenn der
Wind aus dem Westen kommt also wir hören
ja die Windräder von weit weg schon ne
unser Tempo bei neuen Projekten generell
eher schleppend in den zwei Jahren sind
habe ich in China das hier realisiert
ich mache mir für Deutschland sorgen
Stopp and Go also nicht nur auf
Deutschlands Autobahnen ich frage mich
mittlerweile ständig was ist los in
diesem Land geht's noch Deutschland
[Musik]
im Rhein-Main-Gebiet rund um Wiesbaden
und Mainz bricht regelmäßig der Verkehr
zu sammeln Hauptgrund marode Brücken
viele sind baufällig manche müssen
abgerissen werden und neu bauen dauert
gefühlt endlos
[Musik]
fertig
[Gelächter]
morgen ist fertig
an der Schiersteiner Brücke über den
Rhein wird seit zehn Jahren gebaut
eigentlich sollte sie längst fertig sein
gerade rollt der Verkehr aber nur über
eine Hälfte
die salzbachtalbrücke war so kaputt dass
sie sogar gesprengt werden musste sie
wird jetzt an gleicher Stelle neu gebaut
und fällt für den Verkehr erst mal
komplett aus
weißt du wie viel Autobahn ist in
Deutschland gibt wo es plötzlich heißt
das war's und man mitten auf der
Autobahn
so ein Newton macht
weil hier ist nur noch ein Sandhaufen
dahinter fehlt die Brücke
[Musik]
im Netz der Bundesfernstraßen gibt es
rund 40.000 Brücken jede zehnte davon
ist so marode dass sie saniert werden
muss an 1300 Brücken wird aktuell gebaut
wie finden sie die Verkehrssituation
hier
schrecklich wirklich jeden Morgen
Deutschland steckt irgendwie fest aber
warum eigentlich das müsste doch besser
gehen
wie läuft es denn anders wo häufig hilft
ja schon der Blick über den Tellerrand
und siehe da Genua Italien ausgerechnet
in einer südländischen Hafenstadt
erbringen sie den Beweis ein großes
Bauprojekt muss nicht Jahrzehnte dauern
der Anlass allerdings ist traurig Genua
vor fünf Jahren 14 August 2018 die alte
morandi-brücke bricht zusammen auf einem
Teilstück Metern stürzen Autos und LKW
in die Tiefe 43 Menschen sterben
weil das hier genau die Stelle ist und
der ist furchtbar Unglück passiert ist
die Stadt hat die Brücke wieder
aufgebaut in Rekordzeit schon gut ein
Jahr nach dem Einsturz war die neue
fertig ein Symbol aus Stahl statt Beton
entworfen von Star-Architekt Renzo Piano
der selbst aus Genua stand
und man kann das ist nur ein Jahr
brauchte um die Brücke wieder aufzubauen
es macht mich natürlich sehr stolz es
ist unsere Brücke
die Brücke der Bürger von Genua
die Brücke ist sehr wichtig für uns ohne
sie hat die Stadt gelitten besonders die
Wirtschaft hat der Einsturz hart
getroffen
[Musik]
und es ist das erste Mal dass wir sagen
können yes we can wir bauen eine Brücke
in einem Jahr das ist für Italien
unglaublich
sie reiben sich ein bisschen selbst die
Augen in Genua seht her anders als sonst
häufig in Italien können wir hier auch
schnell effizient modern
es musste auch schnell gehen denn jeder
Tag ohne Brücke war für Genua eine
finanzielle Katastrophe eine der
wichtigsten Verbindungsstraßen war
plötzlich weg Schaden für die Stadt 6
Millionen Euro jeden Tag dann gucken wir
doch mal wo der Bürgermeister hier sitzt
das ist auf jeden Fall sehr schöneren
Radhäuser dieser Erde
der Hausherr hier ist Kommissar für den
Brückenbau ernannt von Italiens
Regierung mit umfassenden Kompetenzen
eine Brücke wird zur Chefsache
brauchen solche Projekte also immer
einen starken Mann eine starke Frau die
alles vorantreibt und Dampf macht die
energy exakt
unbedingt das ist eine
Grundvoraussetzung als ersten Schritt
müssen Sie nach einem Gesetz suchen das
Ihnen ein schnelles Vorgehen ermöglicht
wir nutzen Artikel 32 des europäischen
Rechts über die Durchführung von
Ausschreibungen und der liegt fest dass
wir in einer Ausnahme Situation wie dem
Brückeneinsturz selbstvergleichsangebote
von Unternehmen einholen können und
keine offizielle Ausschreibung machen
müssen
Genua schaut also was möglich ist auch
juristisch während wir gern lauter
Hindernisse sehen keine langwierigen
Ausschreibungen hier alles ganz legal
und zeitsparend die reine Bauzeit der
Brücke gerade mal ein gutes Jahr
vor seiner politischen Karriere hat
Bürgermeister Bucci als Manager
gearbeitet zuletzt in der
Pharmaindustrie
kann die Verwaltung also eine Menge
lernen von privaten Unternehmen
die Verwaltung kann von jedem etwas
lernen sie sollte unbedingt moderne
Techniken wie Projektmanagement nutzen
Projektmanagement macht es möglich ein
Projekt auch dann zu verwalten wenn es
im Prozessverlauf Änderungen gibt mit
anderen Worten es ist möglich Prozesse
parallel zu bearbeiten statt
nacheinander das größte Problem der
öffentlichen Verwaltung besteht darin
dass die Prozesse sonst alle
nacheinander ablaufen
wo es früher nur Schritt für Schritt
ging hat diese Stadt einen neuen Weg
gefunden und will damit Vorbild sein
neue italienische Effizienz auch hier
Milano Zentrale der Hauptbahnhof von
Mailand vor gut zehn Jahren hat Italien
sein Schnellzug netzliberalisiert
seitdem hat die Staatsbahn einen starken
privaten Wettbewerber den Italo
[Musik]
also von außen
sieht er schon mal sehr schick aus die
Konkurrenz hat dazu geführt dass die
Anbieter sich gegenseitig antreiben nach
unten bei den Preisen die sind um 40%
gefallen nach oben beim Service
[Musik]
und plötzlich nehmen viel mehr Italiener
den Zug die Passagierzahlen sind
explodiert das ist natürlich das Beste
Anzug fahren wenn man alle Autos auf der
Autobahn überholt
[Musik]
mit 300 Sachen
durch Italien die Schnellzüge haben
eigene Gleise und können so im
Durchschnitt schneller fahren als in
Deutschland und dann natürlich ein
Espressoautomat zwischen jedem Waggon es
ist ja klar
[Musik]
Schnellzug Espresso in Plastikbecher für
1,20 €
über 300 km/h aber schmeckt sehr lecker
wir sind pünktlich am Ziel noch ein
Unterschied zu Deutschland
das war jetzt Mailand nach Turin in
exakt 58 Minuten
[Musik]
Stuttgart 21 die größte Baustelle
Europas
1995 hatten bahnbund Stadt und Land das
Projekt beschlossen 30 Jahre später soll
der Tiefbahnhof endlich in Betrieb gehen
aber auch daran gibt es schon wieder
Zweifel der Bau des Doms zu Speyer im
Mittelalter hat fast genauso lange
gedauert
zwar sprengen Großprojekte regelmäßig
alle Zeit und Kostenrahmen generell aber
geizt Deutschland mit Investitionen nur
Irland und Portugal geben in der EU noch
weniger ihres Bruttoinlandsprodukts für
Erhalt und Erweiterung von Infrastruktur
aus Spitzenreiter Island investiert mehr
als doppelt so viel wie wir
knauserig sein und hohe Ziele stecken
passt irgendwie nicht zusammen die
Bundesregierung will die fahrgastein im
Zug bis 2030 verdoppeln dafür soll auch
das Schienennetz größer werden aber
nordöstlich von Berlin etwa gleich
außerhalb von Deutschlands größter Stadt
sieht die Realität so aus
nächster Halt Werneuchen diese zu endet
hier wir bitten alle Fahrgäste
auszusteigen
weiter geht's nicht aus Berlin oder das
war's
wieder zurück nach Berlin können Sie
gerne mitkommen aber noch weiter hören
nach Brandenburg rein
mehr als 4.500 km Schienennetz liegen in
Deutschland brach mehr als 270
stillgelegte Strecken könnten
reaktiviert werden schnell und günstig
weil die Basis ja schon da ist wie bei
dieser Strecke im Berliner Speckgürtel
der Wriezener Bahn
die Firma von lotac war pinski baut
Gleise in ganz Deutschland für quapinski
ist Eisenbahn Leidenschaft aber Geld
will er natürlich auch verdienen der
Unternehmer würde die Strecke der
Wriezener Bahn am liebsten sofort wieder
ans Netz anschließen doch seit vier
Jahren passiert nichts
das könnte eine richtig gute Bahnstrecke
sein warum Katzen nicht
weil an wen liegt das denn ich glaube es
liegt nicht an uns es liegt glaube ich
an den Behörden ich glaube die scheitern
an ihren eigenen ja an ihren eigenen
Auflagen an ihren eigenen Vorschriften
das ist einfach alles viel zu lange
dauert allein die Freundschaften bei der
Bahn sind schon eine Katastrophe und
dann sagt man noch mal Bahn und dann
noch mal das Land oben drüber das
heißt eine Katastrophe was meinst du
damit einfach zu viel umfangreich zu
viel so kompliziert zu kompliziert ist
das Deutschland oder ja manchmal ist ein
bisschen laut Deutschland
bekommen es war brauchen
nicht nur Montag war pinski ärgert sich
über Quellen und lange Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren laut Umfrage
bescheinigen 69% der befragten
Unternehmen Deutschland größere Defizite
22% sehen immerhin noch kleinere
Defizite nur 4% sind zufrieden mit der
Länge von Verfahren
von der direkten Anbindung an die
Großstadt könnten zehntausende
profitieren argumentiert eine Initiative
zu der Unternehmen Kommunen und ganze
Landkreise entlang der Strecke gehören
doch ihr Vorhaben kommt nicht voran
das zuständige Ministerium in Potsdam
muss sich bei der Reaktivierung von
Bahnstrecken an formalisierte Verfahren
halten und die dauern Jahre
also wir gehen als Verwaltung ja mit
öffentlichen Mitteln um mit den mit den
Steuergeldern der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
insofern haben wir ganz ganz große
Anforderungen an Transparenz unseres tun
es wird auch überprüft von
rechnungshilfen von Landtagen und
natürlich auch von den Bürgern ja und
das ist klar die Ergebnisse die wir
dabei produzieren werden kritisch
hinterfragt werden Nummer Sicher statt
schnell und effektiv ist das das Motto
der deutschen Verwaltung das will ich
von einer Fachfrau wissen sie erforscht
die Bürokratie Professoren Sabine
Kuhlmann von der Uni Potsdam berät auch
die Bundesregierung wie man Bürokratie
abbauen kann seit vielen Jahren
die öffentliche Verwaltung ist ja wie
ich sagte in einen sehr legalistisch
geprägtes System eingebettet das heißt
wenn Sie also sozusagen fehlerhaftes
Verwaltungshandeln praktizieren dann
sind die hier Entscheidungen natürlich
angreifbar ja so dass die Verwaltung
wenn sie Entscheidungen trifft die
Gerichte eigentlich immer im Kopf hat
immer im Blick hat immer schon mitdenken
was könnte mir am Ende
ihr passieren wenn ich falsch handle und
deswegen eher super zurückhaltend und
super kompliziert und konservativ
handelt oder genau ich möchte natürlich
vermeiden dass mein Verwaltungsakt
aufgehoben werden kann dass ich in
irgendeiner anderen Weise sogar
persönlich sanktioniert werden kann
legale Korrektheit also juristisch
keinen Fehler zu machen ist schon sehr
dominantes Kriterium in Deutschland und
das hat natürlich auch mit Personal zu
tun unser unser Verwaltungspersonal wird
in erster Linie nach wie vor juristisch
geschult ja also die sind sozusagen
Spezialisten die wissen wie man die
Rechtsmaterie anwendet und nicht in
erster Linie Manager so wenn die nicht
geschult und das ist auch etwas wo wir
seit Jahren eigentlich dran sind aus der
Wissenschaft zu sagen Mensch wir müssen
die Verwaltungsausbildung eigentlich
reformieren das sich etwas ändern muss
hat mittlerweile auch die Politik
erkannt die Bundesregierung hat sich im
Kabinett auf ein
genehmigungsbeschleunigungsgesetz
verständigt es geht vor allem um den
Ausbau von China und Autobahnen und die
Sanierung von Brücken erstmal soll es
eine Arbeitsgruppe geben
können wir nicht oder wollen wir nicht
man müsste mal Vorankommen zum Beispiel
bei der Energiewende damit so in der
Uckermark fünf Windräder sollen hier
gebaut werden und Strom liefern für bis
zu 25000 Familienhaushalte will nur
nicht jeder Günter Graumann ist
zugezogen und dagegen
es wäre schade nur die Sonnenuntergänge
werden uns vermasselt die die machen ja
auch Krach ne wenn der Wind aus dem
Westen kommt also wir hören ja die
Windräder von weit weg schon ne
die geplanten Windräder würden in einer
Entfernung von 1000 Metern aufgestellt
werden alles nach Vorschrift aber
Graumann reicht das nicht
dann haben wir ständig diese
Ohrwürmer da und sichtwürmer die uns da
ein Drehwurm machen ne die also nicht
die Natur darstellen sondern technische
Überformung die ja an sich wenn man
jetzt technisch argumentiert gut und
nützlich und wichtig und also sowas sind
ne ähm da kann man sagen rund rum werden
über 200 300 Anlagen demnächst da stehen
also über 100 sind schon da und da kann
man sagen diese fünf ne die jetzt diesen
ganzen Park überformen und mächtig
übergestalten die brauchen wir
eigentlich nicht mit der Kritik ist
Günther Graumann nicht allein er hat im
Ort eine Bürgerinitiative gegründet wo
andere vielleicht nur lauter Bäume sehen
Sie die einen prächtigen Park ein Juwel
der Natur visuell bedroht und sie hat
das Denkmalschutzamt auf ihrer Seite die
Behörde ist gegen die Windräder das
Projekt gestoppt Thorsten Volk ist der
verantwortliche Sachbearbeiter haben
hier drüben die andere Halbinsel die
sich hier befindet und sehen wie hoch
doch diese Windkraftanlagen in diesen
Raum hineinwirken es ist also egal wo
ich in diesem Park mich befinde seid ihr
nicht gucken die entgegengesetzte
Richtung sind diese Windanlagen sofort
zu sehen und mit ihrer Drehbewegung
würden die natürlich jeden Blick sofort
an sich ziehen und dann könnte nicht
dieses schweifen des Blickes wahrnehmen
wie zu einer ursprünglichen Komposition
gehört wirklich eine Komposition
zumindest nicht auf den ersten Blick
auch das unbewohnte Gutshaus hat schon
bessere Zeiten gesehen
Katrin Bender und Ulf Sieberg Arbeiten
für den Windkraft Projektierer der hier
seit Jahren plant der Ort ist von der
Politik extra für die Windkraft
ausgewiesen worden weil hier der
gesetzliche Mindestabstand zu den
nächsten Wohngebäuden eingehalten wird
seit 2016 an dem Projekt dran haben
schon sehr viel Aufwand und Geld
reingesteckt in verschiedene Gutachten
gerade auch naturschutzfachlich alle
möglichen Themen untersucht und wenn
dann eben im genehmungsverfahren eine
Behörde mit
Anforderungen oder Belangen kommt die
rational nur schwer nachzuvollziehen
sind ist das schon sehr frustrierend bis
2032 müssen die Bundesländer bis zu 2,2%
ihrer Fläche für die
windenergieausweisen
bundesweit ist da noch viel zu tun und
der Weg ist schwer
Deutschland steht sich selbst oft im Weg
nicht nur bei der Energiewende auch bei
vielen anderen Themen glaube ich die
Politik kommuniziert etwas ganz klar
aber der Teufel steckt dann immer wieder
im Detail laut Bundesverband der
Windenergie dauert es von der Planung
bis zur Inbetriebnahme einer
Windkraftanlage 5 bis 7 Jahre
dahinter steckt ein riesiger
Bürokratieaufwand den kennen auch andere
Branchen brauchte es für ein
Genehmigungsverfahren in der Industrie
vor 10 Jahren noch durchschnittlich zwei
Gutachten sollen es heute
durchschnittlich 7 sein
es sind nicht nur Hürden der Bürokratie
[Musik]
wie das aussieht wenn sich eine
Gesellschaft nicht mehr einigen kann in
welche Richtung sie gemeinsam gehen will
lässt sich im Speckgürtel von Stuttgart
beobachten
Korntal Münchingen 20.000 Einwohner und
ein großes Streit Thema es geht um
diesen Acker um Mais Kartoffeln Spargel
[Musik]
Wolfgang frei ist Investor und Architekt
er ist überzeugt dass er hier die
Zukunft bringt ein Gewerbepark der
Maßstäbe setzen soll Produktionsflächen
gepaart mit Wohn und freizeitbereichen
alles sagt er auf dem neuesten Stand der
Technik frei arbeitet in der ganzen Welt
gerade hat er ein Großprojekt in China
fertiggestellt
was ist der Unterschied zu Deutschland
ja sie in Deutschland ist es wirklich so
dass wir zum Glück ein hohes Bewusstsein
für die Schutzwürdigkeit der Natur haben
für die Schutzwürdigkeit von
Personengruppen haben für die
Schutzfähigkeit von vielen Dingen haben
und dafür gibt es natürlich Vorschriften
und Paragraphen die wir einhalten müssen
das Problem ist aber das ist oft in
partikular Interessen zerfällt und wir
in Deutschland eigentlich jemanden haben
der die Dinge zusammen bringt das ist
scheinbar ein deutsches Phänomen und es
interessanterweise ist auch so die die
einzelnen Personen sind ja sehr sehr
engagiert in ihrem Thema sind vielleicht
sogar sehr professionelle in ihrem Thema
aber umso professionelle sie für ein
Thema kämpfen und sie erneigen sie
einäugig nur ihr Thema zu sehen und
diese diesen Kompromiss nicht mehr
schaffen zu können also passiert mir
sehr häufig dass wir Gespräche haben mit
Vertretern von bestimmten partikular
Interesse am Schluss sind alle
Interessen erfüllt das Projekt ist
gestorben was macht das mit ihnen wie
fühlen sich dabei wenn Sie das sehen
ich mache mir für Deutschland sorgen
also es konkret hier ist ja Porsche
einer der hauptinteressenten die da
einziehen möchten ich weiß es Porsche
dringend neue Produktionsflächen braucht
weil sie ja dringend neue Produktlinien
generieren müssen
gleichzeitig in den zwei Jahren wo wir
hier zu Gange sind habe ich in China
das hier realisiert
das dieses Quartier ist in China
realisiert worden in der selbe Zeit wo
wir hier diskutieren niemand will die
einsamen Entscheidungen einer Diktatur
wo jede Widerrede verboten ist aber
demokratie braucht doch eigene Rezepte
bitte Türklinke betätigen
was hast denn Türklinke
man sieht hier einfach auf
Bürgermeister Zeit für uns kurz
grüßen sie hallo 16 Jahre in diesem Büro
und auch geräumig ja und mit Polizei
Kelle sehe ich gerade ich liebe Polizei
Kellen wirklich halt mal kurz gucken
benutzen sie dir auch
Kollege mitgebracht das ist eine Stelle
der Polizeibehörde als als Bürgermeister
hier
Ortspolizeibehörde Bürgermeister Joachim
Wolf der sein Amt im Juli nach 16 Jahren
aufgibt setzt sich von Beginn an für das
Projekt ein aber noch ist nichts
entschieden das letzte Wort hat der
Gemeinderat also brauchen sie das
Projekt damit diese Stadt weiter leben
kann wie würden sie das beschreiben wenn
wir diesen regionalen gewerbeschwerpunkt
das ist ein Gewerbepark umsetzen dann
wird
großflächig Gewerbe angesiedelt neues
Gewerbe es wird Gewerbesteuer generiert
das ist das kernziel deswegen machen wir
das ganze in erster Linie und wie
sichern damit wirklich nachhaltig auch
die finanziellen Spielräume der stadt
Korntal-Münchingen und diese weichen
muss man jetzt stellen damit sie dann in
wie gesagt für die nächste Generation
spätestens dann auch zur Verfügung steht
wer sich im Ort umhört erlebt eine
zerrissene Gemeinde jeder hier hat eine
Meinung zum Projekt die einen sind dafür
die anderen dagegen genauso wie im
Moment wer von außen kommt reibt sich
erst einmal die Augen ein klassisches
Naturschutzgebiet sieht irgendwie anders
aus
wenn ich als Leihe mir das hier angucke
sehe ich eine Autobahn eine viel
befahrene Bundesstraße und alles
zugekleistert mit Industriegebieten hier
bereits im Umfeld warum es ausgerechnet
dieser Fleck der nun landschaftlich
alles andere als schön ist warum ist der
auf einmal so wichtig wir verfolgen
beispielsweise das
stark geschützte Rebhuhn was bei uns in
Baden-Württemberg auf der Roten Liste in
der höchsten Gefährdungsstufe steht also
vom Aussterben bedroht und jetzt haben
wir noch hier ein Restbestand von
mindestens also bis zur Höhe zwei bis
drei Revieren jenseits der Höhe noch mal
drei bis vier Revieren neben dem Rebhuhn
leben hier auch andere Vogelarten
außerdem macht den Umweltschützern die
Flächenversiegelung sorgen 25 Hektar
Ackerboden wären ein für allemal
verloren
Diskussionen gibt es viele in
Deutschland sind es am Ende zu viele
Anwohnerin direkt ne also das heißt
direkt vor Ihrem Garten soll dieses
Gewerbegebiet entstehen was die finden
sie das
unmöglich ja also das ist ich schließe
sie
kaputtographisch würde das ungefähr 60
Meter in die Höhe ragen ausgerechnet
also sie sind jetzt hier und dann ragt
hier was 60 Metern Höhe
weiß ich nicht was es bringen soll wir
haben ja Ackerland der Leben er
Landwirte
und ganz viele Tiere die schützenswert
sind das heißt egal was der Investor
hier verspricht und wenn er sagt das ist
total nachhaltig klimafreundlich
ist es egal was hier gebaut wird sie
sind immer dagegen richtig
ja
weil sie sagen dieser Acker
ist unwiederbringlich ja genau
für uns der Bürger in Deutschland oder
auf hier weil wir mir alles zu betoniert
dann müssen wir kaufen irgendwo vom
Ausland ich weiß nicht was das bringen
soll jetzt sagen natürlich die
Investoren es kann nicht sein dass wir
hier die Zukunft bringen und immer
einzelne Bürger sagen Zukunft finden wir
auch okay aber bitte nicht bei uns also
Zukunft Spiele
nein das ist doch so es ist doch es ist
es läuft doch gut und Klimawandel und
alles in die grüne Landesregierung
verstehen
wir Deutsche haben viel zu verlieren ist
das ein Grund warum wir häufig erst die
Risiken sehen und kaum die Chancen
wie kommt denn das dass die Leute nur
noch auf das gucken was direkt bei Ihnen
passiert und sagen ich bin für eine
große Veränderung aber bitte nicht bei
mir
das ist eine schwere Frage zum Teil
liegt es vielleicht schon auch da dran
das alles selbstverständlich geworden
ist ja auch der der Wohlstand die
Zufriedenheit man macht sich vielleicht
zu wenig Gedanken darüber was müssen wir
noch investieren du musst dich nur
umgucken wir haben eine Sporthalle
Stadthalle Musikschule das alles muss
finanziert werden muss auch der Bürger
sehen irgendwo muss das Geld herkommen
Kompromisse finden sich einigen trotz
unterschiedlicher Meinungen das gelingt
uns offenbar immer seltener
ist der legendäre Standort Deutschland
zu schwerfällig geworden für neue
Projekte
Erfolgsgeschichten gibt es weiter hier
im südwestlichen Brandenburg ist ihr
Spezialgebiet Lastwagen umrüsten für den
Holztransport ein Marktführer mit fast 5
Millionen Euro Jahresumsatz der Probleme
hat mit dem Internet die Bandbreite
reicht nicht mal für ordentliches WLAN
in der Halle
zum Nachteil dass man halt immer durch
die Gegend rennen muss immer nachfragen
sich Sachen eher fragen muss und so und
so kann man sich selbstständig kurz und
knapp auf direktem Wege kann man sich
die Daten selber raussuchen für
schnelles Internet reicht der Anschluss
nicht aus die Videokonferenzen hier eine
einzige Geduldsprobe wenn
Geschäftspartner das mitbekommen wird es
schnell unprofessionell
die Audioverbindung ist irgendwie ja
manchmal ein bisschen abgebrochen aber
gut
ja ja
schuld das ist die Internetverbindung
Alltag für Geschäftsführerin Nadine
Eisner ihr Unternehmen wird seit Jahren
in seiner Entwicklung ausgebremst wie
digital würden Sie denn Ihr Unternehmen
aktuell beschreiben
Skala von 1 bis 10 zum Beispiel zehn ist
total digital Null ist überhaupt nicht
digital
auf einen schnellen Glasfaseranschluss
warten Sie hier seit fast fünf Jahren
[Musik]
oh ganz klein bis hin ist das
Glasfaserkabel gekommen und und was ist
jetzt das Problem das Problem ist dass
jetzt quasi noch die Verbindung zu
unserem Serverraum fehlt weil der ist ja
nicht hier sondern der ist quasi in der
ersten Etage und die Verbindung dann von
dem Server zur Telekom dass das
Glasfaser auch durchgesplittet wird das
ist noch das Problem
sein wenn das Glasfaserkabel bereits
hier ist dachte ich auch
das ist nicht so schwer ist aber es
dauert halt alles seine Zeit und wir
sind ja auch nicht die einzigen die
angebunden werden müssen das wird man
erfährt man dann immer wieder von der
Telekom sondern es sind ja mehrere die
warten und dann gibt's so eine
priorisierungsliste und da sind wir
offensichtlich nicht ganz oben das heißt
wir reden quasi jetzt nur noch von ein
paar Metern und einem Schalter der
irgendwie umgelegt werden
es gibt aktuell eben kein schnelles
Internet hier kein Breitbandanschluss
obwohl das Kabel da wäre
Nadine heißt na selbst kann da nichts
machen die Kabel hier sind Sache des
Anbieters bis 2025 wollte die letzte
Bundesregierung überall für schnelles
Glasfaser Internet sorgen die aktuelle
Regierung verspricht das nur noch für
die Hälfte aller Haushalte und
Unternehmen haben Sie den Eindruck dass
das ernst genommen wird wenn da jemand
kommt wie sie als Managerin und sagt
Leute ich brauche für das Geschäft
nein
also weil ich denke da müssten wir
tatsächlich sonst müssen wir schon
weiter sein wenn das wirklich ernst
genommen werden würde und wir sind ja
nicht die einzigen also wir haben ja
sehr viel weiße Flecken hier noch in
Deutschland und das ist nicht nur ein
Brandenburg so sondern das ist
deutschlandweit zu spüren zwar legt
Deutschland beim Glasfaserausbau an
Tempo zu im internationalen Vergleich
liegt es aber mit einem Anteil von 8,1%
weiterhin abgeschlagen auf einem der
hinteren Plätze zum Vergleich bei den
Spitzenreitern Spanien Japan und
Südkorea werden bereits mehr als 80%
aller Breitbandanschlüsse per Glasfaser
realisiert
aber Digitalisierung ist ja mehr als nur
ein schneller Internetanschluss
Alena Bata studiert Politikwissenschaft
an der Uni Halle
sie ist auf BAföG angewiesen ihren
Antrag konnte sie online stellen danach
kam erstmal nichts
ich musste vier Monate auf meinen Bafög
warten der Weg von der Antragstellung
bis zur wirklichen Auszahlung war viel
zu lang und ähm ja unausbar für das war
so 3700 € weg waren die nicht da waren
wie Alena mussten im vergangenen
Semester viele Studenten gleich mehrere
Monate auf ihr Bafög warten
was ist da los Alena fragt nach beim Amt
ich habe heute nach dem Stand gefragt wo
mein Bafög-Antrag quasi liegt wie lange
ich noch warten müsste sie konnte mir
keine genaue Zeit sagen und sie meinte
ihm das Problem ist eben dass ja ich
meinte die Bürokratie ist das Problem
mit seit zwei Jahren können Studenten
ihren Antrag online stellen aber hat
sich deshalb viel geändert
die Erwartungshaltung ist eben auch
gerade mit Artikel mit der
Digitalisierung ja ist extrem hoch außen
nach außen hin jeder denkt jetzt ganz
schnell jetzt geht's ganz einfach jetzt
ist nur noch Knopfdruck auszulösen nee
das ist ihm nicht der Fall ja es ist die
bearbeitungs- genau die gleiche
geblieben vom Aufwand her ja er hat die
gesetzliche Grundlage ist da die
eingehalten werden muss die werden muss
und das hat sich nicht geändert und so
stapeln sich die Papierberge im
Bafög-Amt weil die elektronische Akte
für Studenten noch auf sich warten lässt
werden die online-anträge nicht digital
verwaltet sondern in Ordnern abgeheftet
der Antrag klappt online aber am anderen
Ende der Leitung wartet der Drucker
allein hier bis zu 10.000 Blatt Papier
jeden Tag
umständlich zu sein ja warum das so ist
aber es muss ihm alles Schritt für
Schritt gehen ja
es kann nur mal nicht alles mit einmal
passieren ja Schritt für Schritt Antrag
für Antrag papier ist geduldig auch 2023
in Deutschland Digitalisierung zum
Ausdrucken in deutschen Ämtern kann
Einzelfall
[Musik]
in Hamburg wollen sie es besser machen
ein Workshop beim Amt für IT und
Digitalisierung es geht um die Zukunft
der Verwaltung
bei uns internen vertieften Austausch
dazu also horizontal
[Musik]
weniger hierarchisch und mehr gemeinsam
über behördengrenzen hinweg bislang
alles andere als selbstverständlich
das hat schon was mit unserem föderal
Ismus wir sind mit 16 Einheiten und Bund
wir machen uns das schwer wir sind da
sehr auf
Gesamtregelung und Regelung bis ins
dezidierte letzte Detail und insofern
nicht so Risiko bereit glaube ich was
ist denn ihr Traum in zehn Jahren
durften
wo sind wir da
ich glaube also mein Traum wäre wir
werden immer mehr proaktiven Verwaltung
also jetzt wirklich aus meinem Blick
Verwaltung ich werde dann von der
Verwaltung er erinnert dann ein
passläuft ab hier wird es hier
QR-Code gleich verlängern also so eine
proaktivere Verwaltung die allen so
freundlich positiv erinnert und und dass
das gut ankommt das wäre mein Traum
damit dieser Traum wahr wird müsste
allerdings noch einiges passieren
seit 2017 gibt es das Online
zugangsgesetz danach sollten eigentlich
schon bis Ende 2022 alle Behördengänge
Online möglich sein aber von den derzeit
580 behördenleistungen stehen aktuell
gerade einmal 127 digital zur Verfügung
wie Verwaltung aussehen kann die
mitdenkt zeigt ein Pilotprojekt in
Hamburg in den Geburtskliniken der Stadt
können Eltern einen neuen Service nutzen
hallo
neben dem Elternglück
natürlich die beantragungsgeschichte
aber es gibt hier eine gute Nachricht
Kindergeld
Geburtsurkunde was man halt alles so
braucht für ein Kind sogar eine neue
Steuernummer war ein bislang 19
seitenanträge und jetzt die gute
Nachricht für Sie
es sind jetzt nur noch drei und man kann
auch alles online machen damit möchte
man sich eigentlich auch nicht
beschäftigen in der Babyzeit werden am
liebsten nur nach Babyklamotten und
Bettchen und all dem geschaut
sie hat das möglich gemacht
Projektleiterin Brigitte Klamroth es war
ein langer Weg drei Jahre von der
Planung bis zum Angebot in allen
Geburtskliniken aber jetzt arbeiten
verschiedene Behörden auf Bundes- und
Landesebene zusammen die Daten müssen
nur einmal angegeben werden und das geht
auch online
hier können Sie jetzt Geburtsurkunden
bestellen okay toll ich würde sagen wir
nehmen mal eine geburtstag soll ich mal
machen ich nehme eine Geburtsurkunde das
reicht jetzt erstmal weil ich denke mal
es ist auch teuer wenn man mehrere er
sagt Ihnen dann wie viel das ist da
unten und das ist auch der Vorteil
Online-Dienst rechnet er das sofort aus
ich sehe gerade wenn man zwei
tendenziell sogar preiswerter pro
Geburtsurkunde dann nehme ich immer zwei
Geburtsurkunden aus vielen Formularen
wurde eins die Eltern können es direkt
im Krankenhaus abgeben Behördengänge
sparen und Zeit geben Ratschlag als als
jemand der dies geschafft hat wie bricht
man diese verkrusteten Strukturen auf
was würden Sie sagen sie müssen
neu denken aber Sie müssen natürlich
auch wissen wie Verwaltung funktioniert
die technische Basis ist die einfachste
ja sie müssen also die schwierigste ist
am Anfang sich wirklich rein zu denken
wir sind die Prozesse heute und wie muss
ich sie neu denken vom Kunden aus und
wenn sie das gemacht haben dann müssen
sie es verkaufen jetzt interessant von
Kunden reden das ist finde ich ganz
angenehm eigentlich wenn jemand in der
Verwaltung mich als Kunden bezeichnet
fühlt man sich gleich besser als wenn
man so Antragsteller ist oder wann sind
wir denn so weit dass man tatsächlich
überall in der Verwaltung Kundinnen und
Kunde ist ich glaube das passiert jetzt
gerade dass wir auf diese Reise gerade
gehen die Verwaltung kann sich das
eigentlich gar nicht mehr leisten sie
hat so wahnsinnig viele unterschiedliche
und massenhafte Dienstleistungen die Sie
zusätzlich jetzt bekommen haben
dass wir uns nicht mehr leisten können
so zu arbeiten wie es vorher war
bei der Digitalisierung von Gesellschaft
und Wirtschaft belegt Deutschland im
EU-Vergleich von 27 Plätzen gerade
einmal den 13 hinter Spanien und Malta
ganz vorne die skandinavischen Länder
wieder einmal
wieso bekommen die das hin auf der Suche
nach Antworten in Dänemark Wetter wie
bei uns so viel anders können die denn
nicht sein oder doch
deutsche Camper an der dänischen Küste
müssten da mehr wissen
hören Sie uns mal kurz erzählen was so
toller Dänemark ist
die ja dieses gemütliche das ist einfach
so dieses entspannte ne auch hier die
Arbeit oder so ne es ist einfach
entspannter hier das ist weiß ich nicht
wie kann man das denn lernen wie kriegen
wir das denn bei uns irgendwie auch hin
ich glaube dazu sind wir zu sehr deutsch
das ist alles entspannter hier ja die
Leute sind das ist kann man mit
Deutschland
es ist ein Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht
ja und das sind die Deutschen nicht das
ist einfach so merke ich selber auf
Arbeit die sind alle gestresst ich muss
ich muss ich muss und
wie ist es nicht so ist einfach so und
wie können wir uns davon ein bisschen
was abschneiden
wir bleiben zwei Wochen auf der
Rückfahrt ist die garantiert fertig
Baustelle die Bedeutung ja in
Deutschland ist die Baustelle noch nicht
mal genehmigt oder abgenommen oder ich
weiß nicht was weiß ich da brüte da
hängen Vogel den man nicht stören darf
beim Brüten so ist das in Deutschland
harte Worte
in Lübeck treffe ich einen der weiter an
den Standort Deutschland glaubt und das
als denn
Schleswig-Holsteins Wirtschaftsminister
Klaus Ruhe Matzen zu Gast auf einer
IT-Messe lange parteilos ist der vor
kurzem in die CDU eingetreten Madsen ist
der erste ausländische Landesminister in
Deutschland hat selbst in seiner
Politkarriere Erfolge und Misserfolge
erlebt was können wir von der dänischen
Grundeinstellung mitnehmen also allein
dass wir als Deutschland ist aufgegeben
haben das finde ich schon ziemlich
dramatisch man muss ja nicht am Ende
dann erster werden aber wenn man von
vorne rein sagt mal gucken wo ich so
Mittelfeld Lande da müssen wir alle wo
man landet also von daher glaube ich
müssen ja ein bisschen mehr Mut zusammen
greifen und sagen dass Deutschland ganz
nach vorne kommen möchte
Klaus rohe Matzen hat seit neuestem auch
die deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft und
bleibt im Herzen doch immer Dehner
auf das ganz große Bild gucken für einen
Moment Sieg haben ja ein Vergleich sie
können Dänemark vergleichen mit
Deutschland gibt es dann
Mentalitätsunterschiede ganz
grundsätzlich sind die ja also das ist
ein sehr großer pragmatischer
Unterschied in Dänemark jetzt vieles
pragmatisch umgesetzt es wird versucht
und dann wird man feststellen was gut
oder nicht das ist ja im Grunde genommen
so wie bei einem iPhone irgendjemanden
hat mal das erste iPhone gemacht dann
gab sie Weiterentwicklung und die wurden
immer besser wir in Deutschland würden
wahrscheinlich immer noch anders
entwickeln von iPhone hier sitzen und
Arbeitsstation Markt zu bringen und
deswegen müssen wir ein bisschen mehr
Mut haben Themen umzusetzen
wenn es nur so einfach wäre aber
wahrscheinlich ist das schon wieder ein
sehr deutscher Satz
Umdenken beginnt im Kopf
noch mal zurück was sie gerade gesagt
haben das finde ich total interessant
dass wir in Deutschland dazu tendieren
wenn wir eine Lösung suchen die absolut
perfekte Lösung zu finden und dann
gerade deswegen stolpern es gar nicht
hinkriegen am Ende oder komplex weil wir
bei jeder Thematik dann sagen ja aber
was wenn das und wenn ich jetzt so mache
also das kennen wir alle wenn wir
anfangen sehr feinstrukturiert ist
auszumalen was wir uns vorstellen kommen
natürlich immer mehr auf schon wo
irgendwas schief gehen kann und
möglicherweise könnte man einfach sagen
wir starten jetzt und dann werden wir
lernen lernen und das ist etwas was wir
in Deutschland glaube ich jetzt lernen
müssen wenn wir uns international
aufstellen wollen dass wir viel stärker
diesen Gedanken machen wir machen eine
simple Lösung ist simple wir sollten gar
nicht so viel über sprechen aber wir
haben ein Wort das heißt
YT ja als egal ist so muss man mit klar
kommen tschüss sehr gesundes Wort hilft
auch ein bisschen
egal
nee das stimmt ja egal ist nicht unsere
Stärke nee sollten wir ändern ist sie
mir egal vielleicht im Leben ja egal das
klingt dann wieder in Deutschland
gefährlich geworden
[Musik]
die Probleme haben wir alle beschrieben
die Frage ist jetzt die kommen dann
wieder raus ja
die Lösung die man alle erhofft
man muss einfach in die pette kommen und
kann nicht die ganze Zeit diskutieren
diskutieren diskutieren das bringt
einfach nicht einfach mehr Mut um in die
Zukunft zu gehen ja weniger Angst vor
der Zukunft was wäre denn ihr Appell an
Deutschland und die Deutschen ein
bisschen mehr mit der Stimmung arbeiten
weil wir haben einen wahnsinnige
Manpower oder auch Frauenpower in dem
Sinne und wenn wir alle ein bisschen
mehr zusammenrücken wir können schon
eine Menge leisten hier
kreuz und quer durch Deutschland so
viele Geschichten über Bedenken
Stillstand
aber überall auch Menschen die das
ändern wollen die sich nicht abfinden
mit ihrer Heimat als Land des kleinsten
gemeinsamen Nenners satt und matt die
Ideen haben und Lust gemeinsam
anzupacken und Mut aufbringen mit dem
sich Neues schaffen lässt vielleicht
nicht immer gleich perfekt vielleicht
nicht bis ins Detail geplant vielleicht
gerade deshalb erfolgreich
[Musik]